suplementar B9 mesmo sendo metilfolato
sem precisar faz mal alimenta câncer bem
a B9 você sabe que é o folato é um
nutriente essencial pro corpo
especialmente paraa produção de células
sanguíneas e o desenvolvimento fetal
durante a gravidez o metilfolato é uma
forma ativa da vitamina B9 que é o ácido
fólico que o corpo pode utilizar de
forma direta então tomar suplementos de
metilfolato geralmente não causa mal
desde que seja consumido dentro de doses
aceitáveis e adas no entanto é
importante tomar alguns cuidados tem
algumas precauções existem interações
medicamentosas tá o metilfolato ele pode
interagir com certos medicamentos como é
o caso dos anticonvulsivantes e alguns
medicamentos que são utilizados no
tratamento do Câncer Então tem que ficar
atento com isso você tiver nessas
situações específicas conversar com o
seu médico para que você entenda se você
pode tomar Mi folato se você tá dentro
de uma dessas duas categorias que eu
acabei de falar e tem as doenças
genéticas as pessoas com certas
condições a mais comum é a deficiência
de mthfr que é metil teta
hidrofolio antes de começar a
suplementação com metilfolato porque ele
pode precisar de uma dose um pouco mais
alta e pode precisar também Associação
de outras vitaminas no complexo B E é
raro mas existe sim o excesso de consumo
de ácido fólico ou metilfolato isso pode
causar o quê uma am mascaramento da
deficiência de Bed levando a problemas
neurológicos portanto é importante você
usar sempre as vitaminas do complexo B
equilibradas Então se tá tomando
metilfolato é bom tomar as outras do
Complexo B especialmente metilcobalamina
quanto a questão do metilfolato
alimentar câncer não tem evidências que
eu conheça que surgiram que a
suplementação com esse suplemento vai
causar crescimento de células
cancerígenas no entanto é importante
notar que o folato tem um papel complexo
metabolismo celular e em alguns casos
altas doses de folato pode afetar não
criar o câncer mas afetar o tratamento
de certos tipos de câncer então o
metilfolato é geralmente seguro quando
tomar nas doses recomendadas e sobre
Orientação médica se você sabe o que
você tá fazendo se você tem preocupações
específicas é melhor você procurar um
profissional de Saúde nutricionista o
médico para ser orientada de forma
adequada